sexual assault a major problem on
college campuses a lot of powerful
people think so activists documentary
filmmakers and even the Obama
administration are pushing for policies
that take away accused students due
process rights but what if everything
the government thought it knew about
campus rape was actually wrong for more
than a decade policy makers have worked
off the assumption that ninety percent
of college rapists are serial predators
who plan out their attacks beforehand
it's based on a 2,000 to study by
psychologist David Lee sac who surveyed
1,800 men at a commuter school about
their histories of sexual violence the
subjects of Lee sex study weren't as
specifically about rapes they committed
in college in fact the subjects weren't
even all students and yet this deeply
misleading research is cited in the
hunting ground a documentary about
campus rape in Jon Krakauer book on the
subject missoula and even by the White
House's anti-rape task force dr. Murray
causes co-author of a new study that
disputes lee sex work and we sac is
doing everything he can to discredit it
the group of people I worked with were
interested in examining the serial rape
assumption because it's been around for
a long time and the last study was in
2002 the serial rape hypothesis is
widely used it's a foundation for how
campus police think about who they're
looking for the campus judicial response
is oftentimes designed in ways that
assume a serial predator policy even at
the federal level is also makes frequent
reference to serial predators we found
that there were three patterns that men
showed and there wasn't the fourth the
fourth that we didn't find was the
consistently high pattern of man raping
over and over again over time if
colleges and policymakers continue to
focus on a serial rapist
conceptualization they're going to miss
more than three-quarters of the rapes
that happen on
but they're going to end up with a
policy that's directed at a much smaller
proportion of the problem than what we
had previously believed based on dr. Lee
sex 2002 paper we sent the research to
the Journal of the American Medical
Association because we thought it was
important work and at the same time we
wanted it to have the highest level of
scrutiny for its soundness as science
the immediate response was pretty
positive however a group of people
including dr. Lee sac and James hopper
expressed concerns about the paper in
fact there were a few errors in coding
and that they helpfully identified for
us and we were able to correct them so
that the published version of the
article has these small errors corrected
and the effect on the results was it
made stronger in opposition to the
serial rape hypothesis the editors gave
us a good going-over we reran all the
analyses we reran an additional analysis
that they requested they re reviewed the
entire paper the decision was that the
paper is sound it stands the reason the
interpretations are supported by the
findings and that the implications were
logical given the findings so we thought
that was going to be the end of it
unfortunately a research misconduct a
case has been opened by dr. hopper and
his colleagues dr. cost is confident her
team's research will stand up to
additional scrutiny and she has good
reason to think that given its already
survived a comprehensive review
conducted by janet leigh sac and hoppers
request now we second hopper are within
their rights to call for further
investigation but it's worth asking
whether anything could convince
at this point that their theory is
flawed